mais on est à ici aussi donc ce que vous
dites monseigneur di falco ce soir c'est
que un catholique peut très bien
utiliser un préservatif et tout le monde
faisait des préservatifs c'est pas
condamnée par le vatican
à partir du moment vous ne parvenez pas
à vivre l'idéal de fidélité par exemple
et que vous avez des relations sexuelles
on peut pas prendre le risque d'être
soit criminel soit suicidaire il faut
utiliser le préservatif
je prends le temps des missions de bon
sens non mais attendez ça c'est la
position de monseigneur di falco qui est
à parler la position où la position du
pape c'est la position explique les de
façon claire de l'église il ya aura lieu